we're very good at throwing even our
closest living relatives chimpanzees
can't match the speed and accuracy of
our pitches so how and when did this
uniquely human skill evolve scientists
at Harvard University invited college
league baseball players into their lab
each player made eight to ten throws at
a target while their movements were
recorded by motion capture cameras like
the ones used in Hollywood the data
revealed it's all in the shoulder the
shoulder acts like a slingshot as the
arm rotates backwards the surrounding
ligaments tendons and muscles stretch
and store elastic energy it's this
energy that powers the forward throw
catapulting the ball towards its target
the rotation is remarkably fast in fact
it's the fastest motion the human body
produces a chimps ability to throw is
limited by its high shrugged shoulders
our shoulders sit lower and face
outwards giving us a greater range of
motion and allowing us to store far more
elastic energy in the shoulder notice
how this pitcher is able to rotate his
arm more effectively than the chimp
scientists think that our ability to
throw evolved about two million years
ago in our ancestor Homo erectus back
then it was used for hunting now when we
do all our hunting in supermarkets we
use the same skill for sport or having
fun in the park